bonjour à tous si vous nous rejoignez
n'hésitez pas à venir dans le chat aussi
si vous m'entendez bien je suis en même
temps aujourd'hui 7 things
s'élancer
voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire quand vous
rejoignez le chat en même temps que je
vois que je vois que tout marche
de mon côté
ça fonctionne
[Musique]
bonjour vous inquiétez pas photo mais
pas de son c'est normal c'est que j'ai
entendu que les sceptiques en même temps
dites moi dans le chat ainsi si vous
voyez bien là et vous entendez la voix
si vous avez bien l'écran avec envergure
dessus
je vérifie que tout le monde a bien
sonné bien ces deux motifs
du coup aujourd'hui je pense que vous
avez dû voir les les tweets qui sont
passées on va parler de deux énormes
prospects attendus pour la prochaine
draft 2022 on va parler de john hayes
vicat les blogs
sont tous les deux des grands garde si
vous me suivait depuis un petit peu de
temps salut fav vous savez que j'attends
les petits pivot mais que j'aime aussi
l'écran l'écran garde c'est quelqu'un
qui est très pratique le basket ball
avec stack mec de très grande taille
donc on va reparler de ces deux gars-là
ivy love
les deux sont des prospects qui était
attendue l'an dernier surtout calais
bluff et de sons des sophomores jeddah
et viau la plupart d'entre nous qui
l'avons découvert lors de son hub 19 où
il a été exceptionnel avec l'équipe
américaine qui va remporter la médaille
d'or contre l'équipe française en finale
notamment on a découvert ce profil
athlétique incroyable cet arrière qui va
très très vite en transition qui monte
très haut qui aussi mais des tirs on
avait un petit peu suivi son son début
du côté de lourdes ou non la prenais pas
forcément un joueur aussi spectaculaire
en tout cas aussi fort que cette année
il est titulaire indiscutable et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle là on
pourra pas streamé le vendredi on savait
que d'habitude on se rejoint plus tôt le
vendredi soir avec alan quand il est là
où moi tout seul cette fois ci c'est
noël donc forcément on va passer du
temps avec notre nouvelle ligue
respective donc voilà on se retrouve
pour ces deux joueurs là je vais
attendre un tout petit peu de voir si
tout le monde allait les notifications
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans le dans le
chat et à partager le lien du stream et
ensuite on va partir ensemble genre du
film évidemment mais avant sur un petit
un petit point statistiques alors si
vous entendez du bruit derrière moi
c'est que j'ai mes trois chats qui sont
dans la pièce et qui surveille
si tout se passe bien
donc voilà soyez pas surpris s'il ya des
mois où c'est de mon côté c'est des
grattements c'est de mon côté ils valent
absolument passer du temps avec leur
papa donc voilà bah écoutez moi ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on regarde déjà
le profil sur le site envergure tda navy
hier si vous nous suivez régulièrement
il ya vous avez vu qu'un article 1
scouting report est sorti notre premier
scouting report totalement anglais il
est écrit par ben benoît lelièvre sur
twitter qui vit au canada donc bilingue
et qui nous a sorti un petit footing des
portes en anglais on essaie de
démontrer à l'international ce qu'on
peut faire aussi et je vais vous mettre
ça sous les yeux et on va regarder ce
que ben écrit on va comparer avec dia
mon avis puis ensuite avec le film alors
ses lacets près
au peuple a dit moi si vous voyez bien à
l'écran lucide qui s'affiche avec les
stats et cetera si c'est assez gros pour
vous ou non pendant ce temps là moi je
fais un petit un petit retweete vite
fait
pour redire à tout le monde qu'on est
bien en live
c'est l'impression qu'il natif aussi
elles sont pas forcément passer comme ça
monte en europe on est parti jaden avis
donc diana la vie à peine de 20 ans on a
un combo américain on a les photos ici
ouais j'ai peut-être un peu zoomer il
faut regarder c'est là dessus on a les
photos ici qui sont été prises
par la fiba lors du championnat nous je
pense que ça c'est le championnat u19
ici voilà on a donc un mètre
quatre-vingt-treize une envergure mesuré
à 2 104 cm ben le dit dans son art dans
son footing report les chiffres sont pas
encore définis on lit parfois 204
parfois 210 cm on va devoir attendre des
chiffres officiels qui vont sortir on
pense avec le combined puisque cet homme
là il ira à la draft on parle d'un
joueur qui a tendu
normalement dans le top 10 voir dans le
top 5 86 kg vous voyez sur la photo ici
on a des muscles qui sont déjà bien
dessinée chez ce geste ce jour là je
vais pas vous faire tout le background
mais il vient d'une famille d'athlètes à
maman est une ancienne joueuse de
bluewin billet une coach donc voilà on a
un héritage athlétique très présent dans
la famille des ivy en termes de stats il
joua pour diouf qui est un des plus gros
programme de l'année dans l'aquitaine
donc dit pen qui est une amie médian
dans laquelle vous retrouvez des
problèmes connus comme michigan michigan
state lino y est c'est donc cette année
le meilleur programme pour l'instant de
la big ten ces purges où il a joué 12
matches on voit 30 minutes on rappelle
que ces despotes du coup sûr des matchs
de quarante minutes on est 16 5 points
par match on a un joueur qui a 5 rebonds
3 passes une bulle quatre styles 0.5
bloc
2,309 heures donc on a un ratio à stoner
qui est globalement 1,5 1,6 ce qui est
pas excellent mais ce qui est pas
dramatique non plus pourcentage aux
lancers francs un peu douté 73% on va
reparler nous ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est l'an dernier 26 % à 3 points pour
un volume intéressant 4,2 tirs par match
cette année 44 6 % à 45 % globalement
c'était le point que avis devait
développer et c'est le point qu'on voit
le plus il ya le plus gros step up en
termes de tir voilà on est à 58 % donc
c'est un joueur qui est complet qui
petit marc et de tous les niveaux on va
avancer sur les autres avancer ensemble
pour l'état d'avancer
on va commencer par août matin match je
le rappelle c'est excusez moi c'est un
site
qui nous permet d'avoir le volume de
tirs dans chaque compartiment est de
savoir l'efficacité du joueur dans ce
compartiment est est ce que le joueur
s'est créé son propre tir ou bien est ce
que le le panier a été marqué après une
passe décisive qui a donné vie on voit
que c'est le plus gros volume de tir de
l'équipe il joue avec deux intérieurs
alors les deux intérieurs se relayent
très bien williams est vrai qu il dit il
sera l'egypte en même temps autour de
lui à des shooteurs notamment sacha
stefanovic qui est une gâchette à trois
points
de haute qualité qui jouera sûrement en
europe ivy on regarde en termes de
répartition des tiers ses traits nba on
à 41% le tir qui sont pris près du
cercle 42 points ceux qui sont pris à
trois points et un tout petit peu de
tirs à mi-distance près du panier
71 % de réussite c'est excellent c'est
vraiment excellent alors vous voyez en
dessous il ya des 80 81 81 on parle
d'intérieur de pivot dominant ici mais
hélas stefano litige en un tout petit
volume 71% c'est du très haut calibre
surtout pour un arrière
à ça on peut l'associer avec le fait que
qui donna il vit un plateau tu descends
de là excusez moi c'est mon petit comme
je vous le disais
ted o'neill vivent souvent trouvé des
lancers francs quand il va au panier
donc là la stat elle vous donne le
nombre de lancers francs tentés sur le
nombre de tirs tentés
moi ce que je fais j'ai ma petite
formule magique je prends le nombre de
tirs tentés près du panier et je regarde
par rapport à ce pourcentage va donc
c'est à dire que 40% des tirs sont pris
près du panier 34% de lancers francs on
trouve souvent des lancers francs sur
les tirs près du panier donc voilà le
ratio est globalement une fois sur deux
parce qu il va au panier il a des
lancers francs ils sont 13 % de réussite
c'est assez faible on en reparlera côté
trois points maintenant
on a un joueur qui prend un gros volume
de tirs à trois points 2 42% on a vu que
c'était quatre tirs à peu près pour 44 6
% de réussite c'est excellent au niveau
n 6 est
majoritairement du catch and shoot 80%
des tirs qui sont prises sont en catch
and shoot voilà ça c'est pour un peu le
profil
avancer on compare ici avec ou explorer
quitte à notre site qui est très
intéressant lorsqu'on fait de la date
avancée et que vous voulez regarder très
rapidement le profil d'un joueur on a un
joueur mois sacré où l'intéressé qui est
top du pays comme on l'a vu à 3 points
qui est top du pays comme on l'a vue
près du panier qui est pas bon en mille
distance on voit 27% à mi distance c'est
pas son compartiment de jeu
on peut comparer ici parce qu'on a que
du poulet ben voilà on a un joueur qui
prend pas beaucoup de milles distance
quand il en prend il est pas très
efficace et sait jamais des tiers facile
qui est une passe décisive c'est
toujours des tirs pris en poulpe
maintenant
on va regarder un petit peu ce que nous
est ce que nous disent les copains sur
j'ordonne ivy les points forts les
points faibles donc vous avez le
scouting et pourtant tir en anglais vous
en avez un autre qui écrit par maxime
qui est notre spécialiste big ten sur
envergure pas tout lire j'ai pas tout
regardé vous je vous laisse de votre
côté vous pouvez avoir le lien je vais
essayer de vous mettre dans le dans le
chat quand j'aurai l'occasion au nom
pendant le life on prend une petite
pause pour faire ça on voit athlètes
plus plus plus on voit très bon
finisseur près du pagne on l'a vu on
voit qu'il ya des progrès à trois points
on rappelle 25 pour son passé à 45% pour
ben ce qui est moyen mais intéressant on
à la création individuelle et collective
alors on va regarder ça jour du clip
création individuelle vous pouvez le
mettre en relation avec
le haut volume de tir en catch and shoot
ici et là difficulté sur le tir à mi
distance ici donc là dessus moi je
rejoins ben on va pouvoir avoir du film
pour confirmer le wendel
on a un profil de joueur qui devrait
être amené à être un des créateurs
principaux secondaire de l'équipe pour
ben de l'état travailler lui ce qui dit
globalement c'est que je trouve qu'il ya
un manque de changement de rythme et un
manque de de décision'' making lorsqu'il
a la balle en main voilà qu'il interroge
un petit peu plus et enfin un point
faible il dit que c'est pas un donc
voilà général c'est pas un meneur de jeu
classique c'est pas un jour qui fait
briller les autres là dessus
moi je vais être un plomb désaccord on
va regarder cinq jours du choix du clip
lui nous explique que c'est un joueur
qui va majorité - existants driving kick
et ça c'est vrai et qui encore des
progrès à faire pour être un meneur
arrière mais pourtant de balle principal
qui va jouer pick and roll pitch and
putt de 20 attaques placées maintenant
que c'est dit on va pouvoir passer à
peut-être ce qui nous intéresse le plus
en tout cas moi je suis là pour ça et
puis j'espère que vous aussi le clip
pour le clip
n'en a rien louper clemi j'ai lancé il
ya dix minutes on a fait un petit eu un
petit sommaire de votre compte de qui on
allait parler aujourd'hui donc ivy et
caleb love et puis on a fait un petit
point statistiques sur le joueur voilà
c'est tout simplement meta4 bois avec le
clip tu vas pouvoir tu peux pas pouvoir
rattraper ça le clip si vous avez fait
nos instincts live vous savez à peu près
comment ça marche je vais vous montrer
plusieurs extraits en vitesse réelle est
au ralenti de ses points forts et on va
essayer et des points faibles et ont
regardé par priorité ce qui doit faire
en nba et on va descendre en fait dans
la liste des priorités donc là alors
pour la qualité je suis désolé c'est
assez aléatoire ya des fois où j'ai du
480p ya des faux j'ai du 720p le film
vous savez chez envergure pour l'instant
des shows de l'amateurisme
donc on n'a pas encore accès à des
belles images comme vous pouvez la voir
dans les cours aux médias d'accord on
espère on espère que à terme on pourra
vous proposer de la meilleure image pour
aujourd'hui j'ai dû 480 du 720p alors
ici notre joueur elle vit il est là
d'accord il est ici je vais commencer
par un petit appetizer c'est un athlète
plus plus plus comparé à dia morin de
comparer à sac la ville on va regarder
ça ensemble maintenant
voilà je pense que je vous ai fait
l'entrée en matière de jedi vie alors
c'est pas que ça évidemment mais on a un
athlète explosif qui monte très haut qui
va très vite sur son premier pas qui va
être à l'aise et qui va
sur de la transition ou sur du jeu
ouvert être absolument inarrêtable sa
lunel j'espère que tu vas bien du 28 ans
plus tard côté de chez moi donc j'espère
que malgré ce temps assez pourri tu
passes une belle journée et on espère un
rebond tout simplement que tu vas
pouvoir prendre du plaisir à découvrir
dans la vie où elle re découvrir avec
nous aujourd'hui
oui oui sacré jump donc je vous le remet
au ralenti
on est là
je cache ma droite je passe mon
défenseur est tout simplement je vais au
panier de nos pieds et on ne m'arrêtera
pas en face vous avez une équipe assez
intéressante iowa qui est une aussi vous
le voyez cette victoire 0d faty est une
équipe majeure de la big ten avec un
prospect qui gagnent murray dont on a
déjà parlé dans notre premier live si
vous étiez là avec nous maintenant
on va parler de la qualité de
en tout cas le niveau de dieudonné
levier sur tout ce qui va être porté de
bonnes notamment sur du pick and roll
donc je vous le mets en vitesse réelle
il est ici notre numéro 23 ya un pick
and roll et en accélération je vais au
panier donc là on est sur une courbe
vous l'avez vu assez linéaire il ya un
bon premier pas et grâce à son aide à
aimer à sa qualité athlétique je vais
pouvoir m'offrir un accès au cercle on
est face à north carolina qui encore une
équipe majeure g6 de vous mettre des
bonnes équipes
dans les clips d'ailleurs on a dit qu'on
parle et deux
jedi vicat les bluffs ils ont été
souvent mis en opposition directement de
ce match là donc c'est intéressant comme
comme contexte pour analyser faire du
clip je vous le remet en 05
jeu catch ya l'écran on passe sous
l'écran j'accélère et grâce à mon amont
et l'ont amené l'embargo et amal
longueur de bras je vais aller finir au
panier efficacement
ici alors je promets parce qu'un petit
petit lag donc je change de mains je
vais au cercle je rentre dedans alors là
je finis pas
ce qui m'intéresse sur ce clip là c'est
ce qu'on va attendre à une billet il va
être défendu yves a tenu par anne
l'ailier un ailier assez développé sa
capacité à aller au contact et par sa
puissance et par ses fondamentaux
notamment utilisé son bras of jour le du
ballon pouvoir se créer un espace donc
là on va y aller tout en puissance va y
avoir un manque de finition derrière
mais ça va pouvoir le projeter en nba
moi j'aime beaucoup les joueurs qui sont
puissants notamment bas du corps haut du
corps parce qu'on pourra avoir une
domination qui va pouvoir se transmet la
télé hier en nba donc on se refait
épaules en avant avec le bras je fait un
écart et derrière je peux finir d'accord
on est sur un joueur on a vu qu'il ya
70% de réussite près du panier donc là
elle ne finit pas mais globalement très
souvent
neil belle finition ce que j'aime la
shoah l'extrait
sait qu'on a un changement de départ
on parle main gauche avec un dribble de
changement droite et derrière je m'ouvre
un accès au cercle tout en puissance
voilà
extraits suivants on va être encore sur
du pick and roll
nom n'est pas sur pick'n roll de cette
passionnée jorane drive iso main gauche
qu'on est face à rennes si state qu'une
équipe est ce ici assez intéressante
avec un prospect
là c'est pas lui qui défend dessus mais
qui va aller pour moi que j'ai en
loterie donc on est sur un départ au
début contestées je passe ma gauche est
en finition je vais finir ma gauche donc
on a un joueur qui peut déjà finir dès
demain je pense que actuellement on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir un mec
porteur de balle sur des postes arrière
qui peut pas finir dès demain pour un
top 10 et villa cette capacité à pouvoir
terminer main droite main gauche
donc là encore une fois tout en
puissance up step main gauche et bien
terminée on va le remettre en 05
donc je peux 21 départs main droite il a
des bons fondamentaux là-dessus main
gauche je vais en puissance et je vais
finir sur les défenseurs encore une fois
toujours un billet il ya un peu de ça
avec moi enfin peut déjà mort en deux
avec un peu moins de flou alors ils sont
très très très très souvent comparé
béninois parle dans son article ah oui
ils se ressemblent beaucoup en interview
qu'on avait dit à des journalistes
demandent à djeddah navy de qui
s'inspire lui répond 'je à mort n ya pas
il s'en cache pas il a beaucoup inspiré
son basket tour jamhour end il ya
quelques petites différences entre les
deux alors le flou je sais pas je ne
voudrais pas et pas calibré le flou moi
c'est un joueur qui me le fait le plus
cliqué peut-être que ça aurait été un
peu plus meneur naturel capable de faire
plus de choses dans la dans la passe et
peut-être que dieu d'un évier plus
proche d'un deuxième arrière mais avec
un tiers un peu plus abouti quand ils
rentreront une bille est
donc ici
je vais être en transition
encore une fois je vais aller finir sauf
que je me fais blocs et ça ça peut être
une des faiblesses de donner vie alors
on est encore sur un jeune joueur
évidemment
peut-être d'être trop linéaire parfois
un peu de tunnels et de d'aller
s'encastrer sur des défenses
ont voulons aller trop vite
on cela refait au ralenti alors y'a pas
grand chose à face entre action vérité
c'est juste qu'il est trop loin il
mettait pas assez de contacts mais dans
tous les cas l'action était bien défendu
on ne peut pas tout réussir mais voilà
ça un défaut qui peut avoir c'est
s'encastrer sur une défense et manquer
parfois un peu de lucidité en voulant
aller trop vite
actions suivantes
là ce que j'aime bien voilà on est sûr
manipulation de la balle encore une fois
chute derrière l'écran on a vu 80% de
catch and shoot donc là l'extrait que je
vous montre ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on va retrouver beaucoup par match
d'avoir dû du tir à trois points pris
derrière un écran ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il est fluide dessus on va le
voir et surtout comment avec son haendel
il va se créer son décalage parle de
choses le fait de changer demain de
changer de rythme et surtout d'aller
chercher une sorte d'écran non-officiel
voyez là on en n 9 caleb love qui défend
calais bluff qui est pas concentré c'est
un des problèmes qu'on va pouvoir
rencontrer tous souvent avec monsieur
love
ici
sur la pose d'écrans j'ai pas un écart
monuments tagués créé je suis main
gauche on voit que la défense elle est
bien placée notamment avec plusieurs a
dit si c'est un peu chargé donc je vais
me baser plus les champs ma main droite
je vais utiliser le corps de mon
attaquant qui pose l'écran ici pour
bloquer caleb love et je vais déclenché
à 3 pour l'année une belle lecture de
jeu je ne remets d'arrière un petit
sidestep foule up ficelles voilà donc
c'est pas un volume significatif pour le
moment je sais poulpe à trois points
mais j'aime beaucoup sa lecture de jeu
et ça
commence à dire la prise de décision
rapide et sa capacité voilà être une
menace dans plusieurs endroits donc
certains pensent qu'il pourra pas
forcément être un gros créateur
individuel au niveau nba mois ya ces
flashs qui me qui me rassure beaucoup et
qui me font penser qu'on a peut-être un
joueur qui peut exister en trail mary
boleyn le un peu à la façon d'un jim
owens effectivement vous d'un sac la
ville actuellement
ici on le retrouve ici on joue contre
aux furies d'allstate noté qu' on ne va
pas faire premier parenthèse mais qu'on
a un pivot john abbott le freshman de
florida state qui adorent des fonctions
des meneurs moi je trouve ça très drôle
à chaque fois donc soyez pas surpris
regardez ce joueur gillet en loterie
pour l'instant personne n'en parle mais
ce mec là ce grand pivot tous faim qui
se prend pour un mélange lait en loterie
on revient sur monsieur jedi vie on est
main droite
et là je vais être sur une situation de
drive in teak donc ben nous dit dans son
article 5 jours de drive in teak comme
jack comme derrick rose à l'époque
comme on russell westbrook effectivement
un bel athlète il ya une prise de
décision rapide ya du bingo times on va
se la remettre en 05
donkey dans la lecture on est face à une
bonne défense collective hop je passe ma
droite j'ai ma ligne de fond je vois led
qui vient
et je vais tout de suite trouvé un
drive-in kikar y avait ce choix là et on
voit que la rotation été placés pour
venir contester ce tir à trois points et
donc je prends l'autre décision je
trouve que c'est très bien joué de la
part de didier danel vie vous voyez on
est ici
le joueur l'a s'attend à faire une
rotation côté faible corner gauche
et lui va casser totalement ça
avec ceux qui qui s'y est derrière le
col le coéquipier ne ne prend pas le tir
et retransmis à sacha stefanovic qui est
le meilleur tireur disponibles je sais
plus a fait qu'israël n'est ce pas ça
qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment la
capacité à faire le bon choix en drive
in teak
on va avoir d'autres situations oui on
va être là nos choix du passing game
commenté donald vie peut exister bat le
mans qui tiennent rôle en tant que
passeur ou en transition en tant que
passeur
donc là on le voit il mène la transition
face à north carolina accélération on
part ma gauche
et on va avoir encore un kit pour sacha
stefanovic qui était en feu
et je crois que celui-là il fait ficelle
il fait fissa la droite
donc on se marre fait vitesse réelle
parce que il va quand même autre donnée
ville l'accélération sur la transition
la défense allait pas du tout placé et
hop tout de suite je peux trouver un
trois points donc là-dessus pareil on va
le voir exister en nba actions suivantes
on encore chaud de la passe
en kick tout simplement la défense elle
collapsing la défense elle se concentre
sur ce joueur et je vais tout de suite
trouvé une peau équipe qui ouvert alors
pour l'instant voyez la passe côté
faible ma faible soit ma gauche
elle est faite à demain moi j'aime bien
avoir des joueurs qui peuvent passer les
mains des deux côtés faudra travailler
là dessus
je clique et j'ai un trois points ou de
situations de passeur
sur pick'n roll main gauche et là j'ai
un pick and pop
ouvert donc de la porsche roxy caleb
frost qui prend le qui prend le pop
voilà c'est un joueur qui peut qui peut
aussi trouver des joueurs des skis et
coéquipier andy quel peuple est en droit
de faire en nba alors la petite toux qui
derrière elle n'est pas indispensable
mais c'est pour le flou ça fait toujours
plaisir petite toupie trois points et sa
honte
wave habitants il est vif il va vite
enfin de gros gros à tête cette fois ci
on a une passe ça aussi c'est très déjà
on a une passe en l'air
ça un jour qui contrôle très bien son
corps on va regarder ici c'est pour très
bien williams qui est un excellent
finisseur près du panier face à annecy
state
la reprise on a fait pas cela qui peut
être ouvertes avec un angle mais on veut
essayer de rapprocher un maximum
williams près du cercle
et donc je vais m'élever et en l'air
toute la défense allait concentrer et je
vais directement trouvé mon joueur où il
ya plus aucun défenseur pour l'arrêter
ici
et on a donné que tout lui
ici on est en transition sur cette
action va y avoir de la manipulation
visuel qui va être fait donc c'est à
dire que notre porteur de balle ne va
pas regarder son coéquipier pour un
aussi bien faire la passe on va vraiment
lâché le ballon dans les moments et on
va voir aussi de la patience d'accord on
va parcourir tête baissée pour aller
finir près du panier on va vraiment
attendre que le coéquipier soit dans le
meilleur accident le meilleur angle
possible et on va le lâcher le ballon
donc on va temporiser le rythme je vous
la fais en vitesse réelle
et hop ça et ensuite on cela fera au
ralenti
encore une fois on rajoute un petit saut
de cabri pour avoir du style mais voilà
on a un joueur qui attend que son
coéquipier - rapid vienne soit bien dans
l'axé que la défense soit bien concentré
sur lui qui est pas d'être possible on
lâche le ballon et on a ensuite un lay
up ouvert pour son coéquipier
tout simplement parce que l'armée la
vitesse réelle on passe au suivant
donc voila moi j'ai pas de doute sur le
fait qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
capables d'exister en tant que créateur
sur transition ni sur pick'n roll on
regarde ici alors là il va totalement
raté le but comme ça c'est un axe
d'amélioration
ben il le dit dans son article qui
manque un peu de deux troupes en garde
ce que ce que déjà faisait déjà mieux au
même âge
diakité aussi sophomore quand ils
arrivent en nba voilà il va totalement
raté le pick n pop alors moi je la mets
trois lentilles pis je vais frisés
donc là on a notre ami brady manech
pivot cinquième année et dans la salle
garcia qui est un pivot aussi ses deux
intérieurs qui jouent ensemble
sophomore qui vont tous les deux être
concentrés dans la raquette
on a ici le shooteur ouvert et notre
amitié d'aigues-vives a totalement raté
la passe
à la il la prend pas alors qu'il ya
vraiment un pass ouverte un tir ouvert
son coéquiper qui est bien placé il a tu
vas falloir encore progresser
l'action suivante alors ce que j'aime
beaucoup et encore une fois c'est
fait dans le détail mais alors là
l'image elle est vraiment pas mal je
suis désolé c'est comment le joueur par
son haendel et par ses réflexes ne perd
pas le ballon il est souvent dit il va
la perdre il manque de contrôle il a
toujours à trouver une petite ultime
passe ou un petit dribble conserver la
balle est pas faire de dt en over ici
ils tombent fatigue lisent tout
simplement vous voyez il ya un petit
dribble entre les jambes pour éviter que
match cleveland du shop la balle et on
va voir vraiment une belle passe dans le
corner assez spectaculaire
et je sais plus si ça rentre ou pas mais
voilà c'est une action un petit
thaïlande qui fait plaisir donc un
joueur qui qui peut improviser qui a
toujours qui a beaucoup de toucher
donc là on est démarrage iso il est pris
à deux voiliers rate un petit peu l'aide
et finit par réussir à la sortir au
dernier moment voilà va falloir
progresser un petit peu là dessus on a
une bonne équipe bien en place
et il arrive quand même à
se sortir de ça et à lâcher une petite
passe
pour éviter de perdre totalement
l'action nokia plein d'action comme ça
on se dit ah rival à perdre à la perdrix
finale par trouver une solution mais
voilà c'est un joueur qui en a vu qui
perd
1,5 ballons par match pour trois passes
décisives donc on n'est pas sur un ratio
de vrais meneurs ou n'attendra soin de
nous plus qu'à 2 ou du 3.5 donc là
départ à ma gauche cette fois s'il le
rate pas le joueur pick and pop ces
qualifs lost et ça fait 3 points
donc l'action suivante on est sur un
démarrage ma droite on s'arrête regardez
le changement de
changement de direction des changements
de rythme il est assez incroyable si je
suis en face moi je tombe par terre
évidemment comment on peut on a un
joueur qui peut dans son haendel dans
son dribble s'arrêter et repartir on
peut enfin un joueur qui peut changer de
mains qui peut changer de rythme qui
peuvent venir dès demain ce qui fait que
je l'achète très très haut pour la
prochaine draft on se marre fait
démarrage ma droite et là je m'arrête et
je repars main gauche et finalement il
n'y pas pas de le ballon de dommage
parce qu'on a un joueur qui n'a encore
pas un produit fini mais on voit dans le
lit flash dans le matériel athlétique et
dans le haendel un très très gros
phénomène je vais lancer le prochain
clip je fais juste une petite pause 2
secondes pour lancer un tir aux tweets
et suave n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires à me dire si si dans le
rythme ça va sinon le son ça va c'est
dans la vitesse ça va ou ou pas du tout
alors juste un tweet
pour dire toujours en live et je suis à
vous
ok
l'action suivante way d'ipswich catch
and shoot donc voilà on a très peu de
régis prix action en cash on en a pas
beaucoup de catch and shoot mais on
pourrait avoir comme ça il a distancé la
nba de largement il ait pu le tirer les
prix du logo ça monte vite
g steel est pas hyper académique
mais ça marche bien encore une fois tir
à trois points de pris le très très loin
catch and shoot donc voilà il ya eu du
gros travail de fait pendant l'été il
sait que ces normes qui doit avoir pour
de la nba ça c'est la même action que
j'ai mis au point je suis trompé voilà
c'est un joueur qui a beaucoup plus est
sur son petit avec qui attire vraiment
nba là en transition euros step et je
suis à travers le contact c'est encore
une fois quand on voit ce genre d'action
là on a on ne peut que saliver pour le
prospect nba donc hop euros step je
prends le contact je finis ma droite se
trouve la faute
on est sûr de la relance encore en
transition un petit hic il passe voilà
c'est un joueur qui va être fonctionnel
qui va vraiment l'existant tradition
alors maintenant on va arriver sur le
côté défensif
je vais revenir rapidement je pense que
nous disait
ce que nous disait ben est ce que nous
disait maxime sur la défense après on va
comparer avec moi ce que ce que j'en
pense
hop
donc
il ne parle pas trop de la défendre leur
capitule être comme ça alors qu'est ce
qui nous dit
tout tout tout tout alors voilà quand il
est concentré web animées en cause file
à la qualité la capacité de diagonale
via rester concentré tout un match il le
trouve très très long et pour l'instant
pour lui pense que c'est un bon
défenseur sur le ballon mais qu'il n'est
pas très bon dans l'aide à dessus assez
assez d'accord on voit que eux ils
jouent beaucoup les interceptions
effectivement il ya une vague de
réactions qui va suivre qui va se
bouclent les interceptions
du côté de maxime on aime beaucoup sa
défense au périmètre encore une fois les
qualités athlétiques choix sur la
défense à périmètre et y met aussi en
cause le focus défensif
donc on va regarder ça maintenant
ensemble globalement assez d'accord on
va regarder on va pouvoir voir comment
est-ce que ses qualités athlétiques en
font un prospect défensif intéressant
mais comment pour l'instant c'est pas
totalement en place chez ce jeune joueur
on rappelle que c'est un gros volume de
jeu il a très peu des mecs qui arrivent
en nba en étant des stars offensives et
des stars défensive déjà fusé pour la
comparaison parce que c'est comme la
compresse mois ses filets depuis le
début de ce live est depuis le début de
l'année déjà il faisait aucun effort à
me reste et il n'y avait pas de repli
avait pas de traverser pas du tout les
écrans nous voilà c'est pas un bon
défenseur en nba mais c'était un peu
mieux que ce qu'ils faisaient - ancien
anthony edwards qui premier choix de
draft y faisait ses gros effort en acier
et l'an dernier en nba premières ne
l'enrayent pas beaucoup non plus il s'y
met je dis pas que jada ellie sera un
excellent défenseur et le billet j'y
crois pas
par contre il ya des outils c'est la
phrase facile qu'on utilise souvent et
il a
une mentalité de tueur qui fait que je
pense que dans les moments clés du match
il pourra se pourra se bouger un peu
plus un peu sortir les doigts et
être au moins avoir un impact au moins
un nul es10 net positif sur le terrain
du coup dans la partie défensive donc on
va se remettre
ici alors renoncer à l'action suivante
c'est pas grave on peut se refaire ici
tu dis un plafond un potentiel très au
fait moi je
je crois dans lequel plafond
enfin jack le plancher est intéressant
avec le plafond tu peux avoir un vrai
poteau des balles principal de ton
équipe idéalement avoir un 2e n leur de
toutes les équipes nba mais quand tu
peux
créer une offense avec
avec des années j'y vois là pour ça que
moi je les top 4 pour l'instant de ma
draft justice point les prospectus y est
les top 4 à la lutte à troisième place
avec
avec jabbari smith alors défensivement
là vous allez voir la longueur de bras
du joueur et du coup comment il se rend
mortel en défense
longueur de bras transition et 68 d'un
dunk on peut rien faire donc s'en va le
voir en biais il va beaucoup insister là
dessus je mets le bras je mets la main
je suis long et je vais intercepté comme
ça
ici j'aime bien sa mobilité latéral avec
le contre derrière alors on le voit
souvent en une scie et en nba je suis
pas sûr qu'il ait des des blocs comme ça
ce qui va m'intéresser c'est la mobilité
alors on a pas de changement de
direction n'a pas un énorme honneur à
une cité ici va pas y avoir de
changement de direction va pas y avoir
de changement de vitesse mais les pieds
bouche bien latéralement n'accompagne le
porteur de balle jusqu'au bout et par
mes qualités athlétiques je peux
proposer une contestation verticale
notamment en énormes blocs dans ce cas
là là là je tiens bien latéralement et
ensuite je viens bloqués
ici défensivement voitures des
perceptions je pense on le voit non ici
voilà en compte est bien dans l'écran
par mes longs bras je slide bien
j'accompagne jusqu'au bout que cela
refaire
il est là on va contester les dans
l'écran parce que je suis l'on vous
voyez le n9 est pas évident feist
quasiment une perte de balle et derrière
dans le drive je conteste latéralement
jusqu'au panier
on est là
je viens aider
et je fini même par un bloc encore une
fois at lettres supérieures et ensuite
sur la transition bas je suis devant
tout seul
et on a le joli tomar pour terminer ça
on l'a notre amitié danaï vie
donc là je vais venir est décoté faible
dans la rotation et en étudier pitel et
reprendre mon joueur derrière donc ça
banny nous dit que il n'aime pas
vraiment le défenseur loin du ballon il
ya des contre-exemples toujours de toute
façon on a pu voir un joueur qui était
quand même assez intéressant sur de
l'aide et reprendre il est très
intéressé par la balle c'est un des
défauts principaux de la plupart des
jeunes qui aiment bien jouer
l'interception il est très porté sur le
ballon et qui peut faire prendre dans le
dos on va le voir mais il pourrait loin
du ballon jure peut-être le moins bon
porteur de balle adverse venir proposer
une rotation avec interception avec bloc
et ensuite partir en transition ici il
est là il checke un petit peu il ya un
bac ça vote donc toujours intéressant
d'avoir un joueur qui peut venir
participer au rebond alors on voit que
c'est un très bon rebondeur pour les
stats que je me rappelle
je crois qu'il en a 5 ou 6 par match
toc toc ouest il est à 5 rebonds par
match en moyenne
il va plus souvent à l'ailé capté que
protéger leurs bons pour les coéquipiers
mais on voit que voilà il ya ce dans un
collectif on peut quand même protéger
leur bon on a une vigilance dans le dos
et on va derrière sécuriser la prise
face à iowa
donc il est là et là y'a pas d'effort
vraiment dans l'écran le voyais les bad
su ya pas d de prendre le repli et on va
laisser l'action faire d'arrière alors
le joueur banane mais voilà ça c'est le
côté on sait jamais quelle j'étais dans
l'avion va avoir
ici là +20 donc on peut comprendre et du
relâchement à une bien on sait que
n'importe quelle équipe peut revenir on
est chauds du très très haut niveau
voilà là on est
on a un problème de concentration voyez
il fait pas d'efforts dans l'écran il se
fait prendre dedans on n'essaie pas de
mettre une opposition et derrière on
revient pas récupérer son joueur c'est
pas clair jour sur le switch ou sur le
lait des reprendre il ya panier
tu voyais voilà +19 il avait fait une
belle soirée au scoring qu'encore une
fois il est pas du tout concentré il est
perdu sur le terrain et une rotation il
sait pas où il doit aller
ils devaient peut-être ouvrir ici
heureusement le
l'équipe adverse ne fait pas ne fait pas
les bons choix et la dernière fois il
n'est pas du tout dans le pas du tout
bien placé donc très mauvaises actions
défensives qui peut nous rappeler duzac
la ville qui sort de ucla par exemple ou
déjà mort est encore une fois où le
joueur il sait pas ce qu'il doit faire
il sait pas il doit aller et on a un
point mort donc en vitesse réelle c'est
peut-être moins flagrant mais c'est pas
beau
hop
autre défaut de john avis c'est le fait
de sauter dans les fentes vous voyez là
il est un peu de retard il vient et
tutti sedan la fin très souvent on voit
un marsupial un peu son être qui peut
sauter dans les fentes et qui se fait
prendre comme ça donc là-dessus fera
travailler aussi
maintenant on va passer à un autre axe
du jeu est ce que ça peut être un joueur
qui joue loin du ballon est-ce que jedi
vie dans une équipe où il ya déjà un
fort porteur de balle il peut exister je
pense que oui pour deux raisons
principales c'est un athlète donc il
peut y avoir des actions de démarquage
comme on va les avoir ici et on a vu 44
% dont 80% de catch and shoot donc ça
peut être un joueur qui peut exister
fois dans la finition secondaire en
quête soit dans du catch and shoot ou en
sortie d'écran maintenant on va regarder
ça donc là on voit et à se présenter il
voit la cut très belle passe du pivot et
jarden couche pour être faire là dessus
on va l'avoir - nba quand il jouera avec
un notre porteur de balle principal
ici on va avoir un autre a qu à notre
quête je pense voilà je feinte je viens
feinte et
le hand of ou tout du moins le la prise
de ballon autour des lignes à trois
points
la défense y on anticipe ici et donc je
me fais un cut
dans le dos du défenseur très belle
passe encore une fois du pivot très bien
de williams que je serais très content
de voir en europe l'année prochaine
et on va finir avec un dunk complètement
ouvert
en
vitesse réelle
je vous la remet ça fait toujours
plaisir aux yeux jolie cote
nous voilà j'ai représenté up the cut et
le dunk
actions suivantes je pense que ça
inquiète ligne de fond n'ont en aucun
cas lui par main droite et chimie oui je
me suis mis à outils un petit actions
supplémentaires nous voilà encore une
fois je rate des marquages cours il peut
très bien finir très rapidement bon
premier pas c'est un athlète il peut
changer demain à vivonne la clim
intéresser ici c'est le changement de
mains en l'air je crois
qu'ils montent main droite et il change
de mort et les riffs fini ma gauche
alors là en vitesse réelle on ne capte
pas forcément ce qui va m'intéresser
quand je parle d'un joueur qui peut
jouer sans ballon
faut savoir que pure zhu le système de
jeu en fait c'est beaucoup de d'écran
ligne de fond avec des floppy donc des
joueurs qui ressorte autour de la ligne
à trois points pour prendre les trois
points comme ça et donc voilà il ya
beaucoup d'écrans successifs canal vie
ils bénéficient de ces écrans pour lui
se démarquer milan pose aussi ici n'y
voit que donc l'équipe de north carolina
et devient un habitué à ce système de
jeu il va aller indiqué un écran il va
le dire à voix haute on ne verra pas la
chollima vu la qualité pas suffisante ni
mode annoncé l'écran envoie août
le pivot adverse qui hélas armando
bécotte va essayer de switcher marc sur
anticipé le switch est derrière vous
allez voir un dunk ouvert donc
là dessus on a du qi basket on a un
joueur qui va manipuler la défense même
en étant loin du ballon pour pouvoir
créer un démarquage pourtant coéquipiers
je vous le mets en 05
nous voilà la g je viens présenter un
écran j'annonce l'écran on voit clamant
décote sur anticipe et honda donne que
du pivot canadien zack et cody tout
simplement donc
ce genre de petites choses qui me font
en plus apprécié un prospect c'est pas
qu'un joueur qui concentrait que sur lui
même que ce soit au delà du scoring
individuel il aime bien aussi tout
simplement gagner et créent du des
points hauts pourcentages et on est
revenu sur l'action juste où il fait
boum voilà c'est ça à décrypter mieux
jedi vie une accélération aux larmes et
pour le plaisir je monte voilà vous
pouvez avoir sur youtube une compil 1,2
et de light ii donne que de taille dit
moi je suis pas là pour pour ça mais ça
fait toujours plaisir et c'est très
vendeur voilà pour notre ami john hayes
vie donc j'espère avoir fait un profil
un peu complet en nba on a un porteur de
balle principale ou secondaire d'une
équipe on a un athlète on a un jour
finir dès demain on a un shooter à trois
points qui a beaucoup progressé
notamment sur les créations de catch and
shoot qui peut jouer avec sans le ballon
on a un passeur du pour l'instant brille
dans le drive in teak donc à la défense
elle va ce focus sur lui pour ressortir
mais qu'il doit progresser dans la
lecture du jeu sur pick'n roll pick and
pop on a un joueur qui doit aussi faire
des meilleurs choix donc oui dribbles on
voit qu'il ya un deuil qui a ses futurs
les deux mains mais de faire de
meilleurs chevaux - perdre le ballon
défensivement on a vu il ya des outils
évident de la longueur du tonus on voit
qui peut bien glisser dans les écrans il
peut se déplacer latéralement mais il ya
un manque de concentration
qui va devoir corriger notamment sur
tout c'est pas la star de l'équipe et
qu'on attendra plus de lui par
projection il est souvent attendu top 10
moi je voulais dis-je les top 4 entre
tous soit 3 soit 4 avec jaden smith ça
dépendra de de l'équipe parce qu'on a
des profils opposés ont un petit veau
hypermoderne
licorne d'or parlera une autre fois
qu'ils jouent à auburn et là on a un
arrière explosif c'est un peu le même
débat l'époque de
bages s'agit pas forcément de
comparaison que voilà c'est comme si
vous vous demandiez à l'époque contre
diagramme jackson junior et dia maurenn
tu
on a une licorne à l'intérieur contre
eux en arrière l'explosif tu veux dans
ton équipe tu m'étonnes que tu veux mais
l'équipe moi je serais ravi aussi mais
mais mais chicago bulls vont être trop
trop haut son coach thibaut ne s'appelle
pas mal ben oui mme thibodeau il y en a
déjà vu un jeune arrière explosif qui
existe est d'abord dendritiques et qui
dominé physiquement il en a fait ribi
pis donc évidemment que ce que de
thibodeau ça peut être une très bonne
très bonne pioche je sais pas trop là
actuellement
où est-ce qu'ils pourraient tomber j'ai
pas forcément le parce que façon salade
de la le très trop tôt dans la saison
mais je pensais à a dit white par
exemple avec un autre porteur de balle
principal j'aimais beaucoup avec kid
houston mais il ya déjà plein de plans
de wenger c'est un peu trop tôt pour
voir ça mais alors là il ya du matériel
de all star pour moi avec tes d'un ivy
d'avoir vraiment un joueur un joueur
dominant dans les prochaines années et
une belle mentalité pour plus d'infos
sur le joueur dans sa bio dans son
caractère et dont le avant juste un
autre avis n'hésitez pas à lire
l'article qui est là je vais essayer de
vous mettre
le mettre dans le tchat je bascule comme
ça et là n'hésitez pas le lire et à le
partager je vous mets ça
ici
donc voilà on va passer au deuxième jour
j'ai fait une petite pause pour faire
pour faire un petit rythme pendant que
je joue mais le le lien alors
et puis on va enchaîner
tranquillement
avec notre copain de caleb love tout cas
je vous coupe le son de mon live au
qu'ici
et
alors est-ce que j'ai le chat qui
s'affiche non pas du tout bon bah écoute
et tant pis pour le lien je leur
mettrais sur twitter c'est pas grave
on va pas non plus perdre trop de temps
là-dessus ok je fais le petit tweet et
choix vous
pour dire aux gens qu'on passe sur
calais bluff
ok alors qu'elle est bluff caleb lowkey
les bluffs
calais bluff c'est en
sophomore c'est aussi un en arrière
combo 1 2 qui joua you when things north
carolina une des équipes les plus
mythiques du championnat nba évidemment
c'est une équipe lorsqu on line à qui a
vu ces dernières années plusieurs gardes
qui sont allés en nba on pense à notre
ami
notre ami collègue toni il ya deux ans
de ça qu'on pense à
kobe white ya trois ans qui joue aux
boules maintenant donc comme un délit au
au magic et leur dernier la grosse
recrue s'était calée bluff alors
je peux repasser là dessus hop là
c'était caleb love la page le tantale
charge ma connexion elle est pas top top
top
sauf que ça s'est pas très bien passé ça
s'est pas très bien passé parce que on
avait une équipe qui était totalement
bouché sur le secteur intérieur avec
deux trois pivots on avait un litige
black ops se délier qui n'était pas un
shooter à trois points bref caleb love
avait aucun espace de jeu bon je vois
pourquoi le site le site galère tant pis
ou passer sur un autre un autre format
et donc voilà on avait une équipe qui
n'avait pas du tout destiné aux câbles
qu'elle est black adam beaucoup souffert
et du coup qui est pas là la draft lüthi
datant du top 10 en début de saison
2021 vous voyez 20,2 en donc en gros 20
ans un peu plus vieux que de la navy
pour une garde mais voilà il fait un
combo poste un poste 2 1 mais 93 aussi
un grand meneur 210 cm d'envergure ça
s'est vérifié
88 kg vous voyez avec un ancien athlète
qui est bien développé il joue à north
carolina on regarde les stats rapidement
l'an dernier il était titulaire aussi il
était à
tout tout tout tout tout tout que les
stats avant c'est
très bien pas de soucis qu un problème
on va les faire comme ça excusez moi la
technique qui suit pas forcément
sportif le nom de city mais le lien
sortir du lot un petit peu avec sur le
sur la page du joueur
donc l'an dernier il était à 10,5 points
on voit les portes agité dramatique 35%
bien sûr que j'accepte les coups qu'il
n'y a pas de souci je faisais
grandissent à 35% du coût de réussite au
global avec
hop là 3,6 passes pour 309 heurte à jour
qui parle d beaucoup le ballon
no qui n'était pas en réussite si par
des beaucoup le ballon ils l'étaient pas
hésité non plus à trois points 1 26%
seulement dans une équipe sans space in
il avait pas beaucoup de lancers francs
tu es alors qu'il tentait beaucoup près
du cercle mais là dessus il efficace
voilà j'aurai vraiment mal être totale
on était à céret et pour la suite il ya
eu un changement de coach robbie
williams est parti à la retraite et donc
ses coaches ukr davis qui est maintenant
à la tête de yuans 6 a pas empêché
calais bluff de rester lui il y aurait
pu transférer il a il est resté et il a
invité
on lui a mis à côté de lui des
intérieurs qui sont des intérieurs qui
peuvent tirer à trois points brady
manech on l'a vu tout à l'heure et
doosan garcia et donc ça a changé
beaucoup de choses pour lui cette année
on le voit il joue 32 minutes par match
il a 43 % de réussite en global ce qui
n'est pas exceptionnel mais qui mieux 45
% de réussite à deux points on va avant
qu'il ya beaucoup de mi distance par
contre 41% à 3 points c'est la grosse si
progression j'ai pris ces deux jours là
parce que c'est des joueurs qui vous
font le même poste ivy et love qui sont
tous les deux se font mort et qui ont
tous les deux eu un
à une amélioration sur le retire donc
j'ai trouvé intéressant à comparer gens
qui ont tué deux attendus loterie on
voit 15,1 points du coup on a toujours
beaucoup trop de pertes de balles quatre
passes décisives 2,6 pertes de balle
donc on est un ratio qui est inférieur à
1,5 ce qui est pas bien pour un meneur
de jeu on a un joueur qui peut prendre
du rebond aussi 4 rebonds qui peut
prendre deux interceptions 1,3 style et
qui après pour les fautes ne commet pas
beaucoup maintenant on va regarder les
stats avancé donc on est toujours sur
you groupe matt on va juste permettre la
bonne page de north carolina
alors nos amis de north carolina hop
vous voyez toutes les équipes avec les
différentes années
on prend ici
caleb love donc c'est le plus gros
volume de terre de l'équipe on voit il
joue avec un pivot mundo bécotte un
deuxième arrière et ensuite nos amis on
a dit brady manach dawson garcia qui
peuvent étirer le jeu qu'on voit 1 36% 3
points 46% trois points c'est ça qui est
à grosse différence pour lui du coup il
prend un tiers de ces tirs près du
cercle et icaf 55 % ce qui est bien sans
être exceptionnel c'est un bon
pourcentage quand même
pour un point de l'extérieur par contre
on voit cette année il prend 30% des
terres près du cercle il a un
ratio
cuissots est entre les files de
l'atlantide qui a 34 % de celle à 200
jours qui lorsqu'il va au cirque trouve
souvent des fautes toujours efficace
près dû au choix ligne des lancers
francs maintenant on a un gros volume de
tirs à trois points 40 % donc c'est la
majorité de ces tirs sont pris à trois
points 41% de réussite ce qui est très
bien est ce que je joue quoi je veux
insister c'est que cinquante deux pour
cent de ces tirs sont catherine tout ça
veut dire que 48 % du temps lorsqu'il
prend un tir à trois points c'est lui
qui se crée son décalage ça les
franchises nba elles vont acheter
fortement d'accord on rappelle le tout à
l'heure ayivi c'était 80 % de tirs à
trois points en cas de chute là on a un
jour qui vraiment secret son décalage se
crée son propre tir extérieur dans
différentes situations et très efficace
malgré ça donc là dessus on achète très
fortement quand on est une franchise nba
on voit ensuite
30% de tir à mi distance quasiment
autant de type en un même pourcentage de
tirs pris à mi distance que tient près
du panier on est à 32 pour fondre et le
site est encore une fois
23% seulement de catch and shoot dont
75% du temps lorsqu'il va faire un
décalage à mi distance il va prendre un
pool up et ça ça va être efficace à 32 %
ce qui est assez faible mais qui nous
intéresse à quoi une fois c'est de créer
son décalage c'est pour ça qu'à avancer
maintenant on va utiliser le film pour
garder que ça donne l'impression
visuelle et essayer de voir un petit peu
les qualités athlétiques les qualités de
haendel et qualité tir du joueur hop
donc
si je vous met maintenant le clip
lequel est bloch
et on est parti on va dans les clips
avoir un petit peu le même m système que
tout à l'heure on va avoir d'abord les
qualités de pick and roll du joueur
qu'est ce qui peut faire balle en main
je connais cette situation de pick and
roll qui est l'âme majoritaire de en nba
et ensuite on va regarder à l'extérieur
de la passe et la défense du jour
d'accord
on est partis n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires à faire des retours en même
temps si vous vous dites aussi 50 fois
je vais trop vite si je vais trop
lentement aussi s'il ya des choses qui
sont améliorées je suis je suis là je
suis là pour ça je suis là pour prendre
aussi des des commentaires voilà on est
pas on n'est pas dans du
professionnalisme qu'on essaye juste de
faire un truc intéressant
premier clip donc on a dit on va sur du
pick and roll on joue face à michigan
qui était une équipe très attendue de la
big ten avec notamment qu'à la bio stone
qui est un des joueurs les plus cotés du
pays note beaucoup de recrues de très
haut niveau et qui déçoit la gt24 trième
du pays avec deux défaites et depuis ils
ont chuté beaucoup de défaites dans
cette équipe de michigan qui est assez
inquiétante on est parti
donc pick and roll
encore une fois on a un athlète
fait le point commun entre les deux je
veux hiver ils montent très haut très
puissante très long donc le pick and
roll l'écran est pas très bien poser de
la bande à rudi garcia
mais on a deuxième écran dans le dos de
moussa diabaté le français qui ici vous
avez forcément entendu parler maintenant
vu que c'est notre petite française
antillais deuxième écran du cou qui
coupent l'aide de la part du pivot et je
vais au cercle je monte je fini fort ça
c'est une action typique de calais de
calais bluff drive main droite finition
dunk puissamment
c'est un peu sa carte d'identité
deuxième action and off je feinte la
prise de la prise d'écran je change de
mains et je vais donner au panier donc
là on retrouve aujourd'hui avec notre
ami ben khedda navy donc voilà l'écran
il est là je feinte laprise d'écran je
vais aussi à clé change pas c'est de la
magouille à ma main droite pour éviter
de me faire intercepter le ballon ici
par ivy et je vais finir très fort sans
aucune aide possible vu que j'arrivais à
trois points ici à shooter à trois
points ici pour finir au dunk
je vous la remet au ralenti
et on est parti
donc l'ice à switch stefanovic qui
peinent athlètes jeu par ma gauche je
change ma droite pour éviter et je finis
au dessus en dunk main droite encore une
fois pour un porteur de balle toujours
très intéressant même obligatoire de
pouvoir
partir en grève dès demain avec un bon
premier pas pouvoir changer demandant
son drive est de pouvoir changer de
rythme c'est à dire accélérer ralentir
pendant le drive et ça c'est quelque
chose sur lequel caleb lever très à
l'aise
l'action suivante vitesse réelle
pick and roll indiqué mme popp ici main
gauche je change de mains je finis ma
droite donc il ya un joueur qui a dû
toucher cas de la fluidité on peut se la
refaire au ralenti
donc main gauche
pitel pop j'ai encore ma gauche j'y vais
et pour éviter le compte de moussa
diabaté qui tendent l'excédent
protecteur de cercle je vais changer de
mains en l'air donc là l'image la
qualité d'image parlait pas forcément
dans le voir mais je passe de ma gauche
à main droite utilise la planche et le
panier pour protéger mon ballon
et tu finis un photographe caprioli
photo à cet endroit là peut-être
mcgregor notre ami marc gork on salue et
je finis mouillac main droite tout en
fluidité on peut surfer en vitesse
réelle c'est une belle action
et c'est bien fini ce
donc là départ à ma gauche spin move et
avec du toucher je finis ma droite c'est
encore une fois c'est une belle action
on est au regard des fondamentaux il a
un bon premier pas il fait bien utiliser
son corps pour feinter des démarrages
l'endroit de démarrage main gauche et du
coup partir à l'opposé le spin move et
avec du touch et je vais finir ma droite
c'est un joueur qui est un bon premier
pas sans être un premier pas élite je
trouve pour la pour la nba on va le voir
plusieurs fois mais il ya un bon premier
pas intéressant mais je n'ai pas non
plus sur un joueur
vraiment supérieur plus plus plus plus
plus jeu par rapport aux aux monstres ou
non en nba donc voilà la veille du
toucher face à une équipe de loyola
marymount qui est assez faible je vais
pouvoir terminer aux finitions flottant
encore une fois sur notre situation de
pick and roll et là on va arriver sur l'
arme secondaire à même la principale
j'ai envie de dire de caleb love le
poulpe à 3 points donc on a pas
d'efforts de la part de diana évident
l'écran on va pouvoir en un dribble
ensuite poulet pas 3 pourront rappel on
est à 45 % de réussite
au global sur le trois points avec un 3
points jour 2 kg et prénom de bouloc
donc là je vous ai mis une série de
clips on voit caleb love dégainer de de
loin rapidement tout seul
noël un dribble je suis face à un
intérieur qui peut pas me suivre et
trois points on enchaîne sur les trois
points le même le même séquence de jeu
quelques dribbles poulet trois points
alors on peut regarder au niveau de la
distance on est largement une distance
nba regardez auxerre un pas derrière la
ligne qu'on est largement distancé le
billet le geste il est fluide
et surtout le le déclenchement et rapide
donc voila un petit dribble
mini-cités bague minisite step
le geste et ra pied le geste est fluide
et ça fait filoche
l'action suivante pareil dit pluie donc
là je suis vraiment très loin un dribble
de drible face à kennedy chandler et ça
fait ficelle encore un autre
toujours ce décalage là on aime bien
moins gauche ont replacé dans l'axé et
je fais ficelles donc situation pick and
roll encore une fois avec un side step
donc je vais prendre le jeu prendre
l'écran passé par armando bécotte qui
est pas du tout menacé extérieur qui est
humain vraiment un petit veau classique
qui rôle et qui athlétique
on voit que ici je crois que c'est elie
brooks qui est un peu en retard joué
agenda il ne tiendra pas ici de la part
du pivot adverse petit sidestep trois
points hop et 30 ans
donc là il est là il demande le ballon
on est loin il appelle l'écran
est derrière l'écran ficelles encore une
fois
ici du coup vous l'avez compris on est
sur le le même move mais appliqué sur
10000 distance donc c'est un joueur qui
peut partir au panier ayivi conteste à
ce moment là du coup l'accès au cercle
et donc je vais faire un décalage avec
un step back pour prendre nos mi
distance on a vu
qu'en termes de réussite on n'est pas
sur des pourcentages exceptionnel 32 5%
mais ça s'explique parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de tirs compliqué près comme ça
moi une bière on verra si on lui laisse
la même chose pas la tendance qui va
intéresser une franchise c'est d'avoir
un joueur qui peut se créer son décalage
sans être hyper explosif il arrive
souvent à se créer un écart est donc ça
les franchises nba devons acheter donc
confirmé en 0.67
donc derrière l'écran
je pars à ma gauche change de mains et
de step back mi-distance yona deuxième
quasi identique je crois je pars à ma
gauche on a un switch
est encore un step back
et ça fait fi seul doigt si vous l'avez
je pense qu'on va vous l'avez compris
c'est un joueur qui est devenu vraiment
à l'aise sur son tir extérieur qui cette
année a de la réussite contrairement là
dernier et que c'est expliqué parce
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de spécimens
cette équipe de youwin si
l' on échange du catch and shoot encore
trop points voilà un joueur qui peut
dégainer de très très loin maintenant
rail sur autre chose que le tir
extérieur on est sur du passing game et
non on est là sur un drive alors oui ça
c'est une des qualités que j'aime
beaucoup je voulais dit qu'on veut qu'un
porteur de balle et une bille et puis
changer le rythme par le changement de
mains mais aussi par le changement de
vitesse là vous allez avoir une
accélération pendant le dreg de caleb
loft quelque chose d'assez rare chez les
prospects qu'on voit pas très souvent
mais ce qu'il fait et ce qui fait les
grands prospects
cette capacité à pouvoir accélérer
pendant son drive sont là des mecs qui
change de rythme en ralentissant lui l'
accélération et je vais pouvoir aller
finir près du panier
donc la pitié drôle
le contrôle dans le film changement de
direction la patience et il ya un tir à
trois points
alors on le voit on l'a vu on y perd
beaucoup de ballons on va voir qu'en
terme de passing game on a fait beaucoup
de progrès à faire
depuis l'an dernier moi ce que j'aime
bien c'est qu'il a pris un peu plus de
temps pour gérer son tempo pour
contrôler le rythme et pour vraiment
faire le bon choix ici on le voit il va
pas s'enfoncer dans la défense il va
contrôler en quelques dribbles gérer son
espace et ressortir pour un meilleur
shooteur brady manech notamment à trois
points donc en vitesse réelle
et que t'as pas de décalage n'y a pas un
rôle je contrôle le rythme je me remets
en place ayant un tir extérieur à trois
points
qui est bien fait la roue transition
maintenant je contrôle encore une forme
au rythme je fais pas m'enfoncer dans la
défense comme il peut le faire souvent
je vais faire un clic pour attirer
extérieur l'a47 fois ci parce que faire
au ralenti
donc au lieu d'aller - castrés dans une
défense qui y est rentré ici je vais
vite fait un petit dribble d'hésitation
et je vais ressortir pour mon shoot
heure
là il demande le ballon
il appelle l'écran
on voyait encore on temporise au ralenti
il ya une très bonne passe alors j'ai
coupé l'action parce que brady manach
rate le lay up et ça me déprime mais
deux choses du coup sur cette action je
vous demande le ballon parce que je sais
que ici monnaies liées par un grand
porteur de balle je vais demander un
écran un petit dribble hésitations et
ensuite il valait lâcher une magnifique
passe ligne de fond ici pour mon à
l'intérieur qui derrière fera n'importe
quoi
donc j'appelle l'écran
mon premier pas gauche hésitation ré
accélération dans le rythme mon pivot se
démarque bien je la lâche entre deux
joueurs et derrière normalement en nba
johan renck
l'action suivante la même chose
quasiment pour un code dans la cadre ça
qu'on peut ne vous la remet
donc j'ai dit actions suivantes la voilà
quasiment la même action j'accélère je
la lâche dans laxe port amende au bacon
et ça c'est une action ennemie mais avec
un petit poids de l'éthique qui pourrait
finir fort
alors ici si je me trompe pas c'est
maintenant le défaut de calais blog je
vous ai montré des belles passes je vous
ai montré du kick je vous ai montré un
peu de pick and pop ya quand même
quelque chose de très perfectible on
peut rater des joueurs ouvert là
notamment je crois que ses doigts sans
dire ça qui va être totalement ouvert
contre toute la séquence et qui va être
raté on a encore un joueur qui peut
avoir des oeillères qui va devoir
progresser là dessus si veut pouvoir
être
important de balle principal nba lui il
aspire à jouer meneur ans il veut jouer
meneur il veut le ballon dans les mains
il pourra pas se permettre d'avoir des
déshérence comme ça alors c'est
peut-être pas cette action-là donc la
pitié pop et voilà si c'est ça
vous regarde et il ya un pitch and pop
le jour est totalement ouvert
et qu'elle les bleus vivent à s'enfoncer
dans la défense de ce qui faisait
beaucoup l'an dernier et compte pas
encore retrouvé donc la pitié pop
la défense des sons totalement moussa
diabaté très très loin et là il rate
totalement ici de l'asean garcia et ses
bras dit manech le pivot qui lit bien le
jeu qui va redonner le ballon
et ça fait filoche on a un joueur de
s'inverser à 40% à 3 points il faut lui
transmettre le ballon la saaq caleb la
ville pourra pas se permettre en biais
de rater des occasions comme ça
ici pick and roll
je suis patient mais je rate encore une
fois là la kz2 passe on a une belle
ligne de passe ici
pour avoir un pivot athlétique avec un
dunk sachant que ça qu'ils disent est
pas un athlète c'est un grand pivot mais
c'est pas de date l'est si je peux
comparer c'est peut-être le futur lucas
gaza si je veux être optimiste pour
osait qui dit on va rater totalement
cette passe
derrière on va aller s'enfoncer contre
la défense on essaie de faire une une
passe aveugle pour un mode au boycott
mais qui peut pas du tout voir le ballon
et ça finit en pertes de balle
étape 2 balles je vous la remet ici sont
coupés en vitesse réelle
al hayat 2 mauvaise décision d'affilée
avec perte de balle et on voit au niveau
du langage qui est qu'il est frustré
alors que c'est totalement de sa faute
l'appareil en transition là je vais
aller mon castrés sur la défense ça fait
alors qu'on a un joueur encore de cinq
gars à ce que voulaient de s'apprécient
pas du tout on pourrait croire
et on va totalement raté le copain
ouvert en transition et ça on pourra pas
l'avoir une vie regardez il est tout
seul ici et on va s'enfoncer dans une
dans une défense
on n'a pas de point facile
là c'est pareil en lecture de jour n'est
pas optimale on va aller s'enfoncer dans
la défense alors qu'il ya mieux à faire
sur cette action là et comme on n'est
pas au nahd athlète intéressant lors du
changement de rythme on n'a pas un
athlète supérieur non plus
dans le contact on voit qu'ils aient
fini à 55% près du panier donc c'est pas
élite comparé à d'autres jours dont on a
déjà parlé ici notamment juste avant le
jedi dit
jean alesi pardon donc regarder donc là
on a un hands double écrans successifs
avec un joueur qui roule un joueur qui
popent action typique nba on a peut-être
une passe qui pourrait être ouvert par
dessus au niveau de la lecture au niveau
des yeux on n'est pas dans l'intention
du niveau de son joueur qui rôle
alors on contrôle un petit peu le rythme
il ya un switch
on a un joueur ouvert ici avec une
surcompensation sur le ballon de
dieudonné lévy qui est très attiré par
le ballon et on va les s'enfoncer dans
le défenseur sont variés on se fait
bloquer facile voilà là c'était deux
défauts maintenant on va passer sur la
défense
de calais blog is it à l'heure on a dit
que notre ami ivy était totalement
inconsistant
calais bluff c'est peut-être le joueur
qui est le plus frustrant là-dessus
capable de faire des très bonnes
performances défensives des très grosses
top parce que ça en athlètes parce qu'il
est très long et puis totalement de
s'oublier sur l'action suivante là vous
allez voir le cerveau et les débrancher
il ya certes début de match contre
tennessee qui est une très bonne attaque
et notamment d'une très bonne équipe
avec un prospect et lydie chandler qui
est aussi attendu dans le top 20 de la
prochaine draft un petit meneur qui
était le meneur qui a mené les us en à
la médaille d'or en 1019 donc à vous
allez voir qu'elle est bluff qui
débranche le cerveau qui fait pas
d'efforts
voilà il n'ya pas deux y a pas d'efforts
s'est passé
et ça c'est totalement inacceptable
évidemment pour un joueur apte à tous
les niveaux on cela remet en vitesse
réelle
petite accélération du porteur de balle
est calé bluffe pas d'effort il est
passé il ya les iops autre action alors
on va commencer par le négatif en
défense
ici il n'y a pas d'efforts dans l'écran
la guitare cette action là on est pris
en retard on va là où il aurait dû
il sait que
la vie n'est pas un joueur qui aime bien
shooté à mi distance et qui est d'un
poulpe à trois points il aurait dû venir
contester dans l'écran sachant qu'il ya
des longs bras sur lui hand of là et
vous allez voir réellement et les appuis
les prends mais il va trop loin il va
passer en dessous donc là il passe en
dessous
mais il fait pas d'efforts dans la dans
la reprise derrière
et y allez hop
encore une fois je crois qu'on est en
transition
voilà il ya mauvaise communication et il
ya un donne que de pure beauté de notre
ami ivy qui
n'en demandait pas moins ça en nba c'est
pareil ce qu'elle est belle la vie va
pas prendre le défenseur il annonce pas
en fait quels joueurs il prendre il ya
confusion avec je crois que c est l
elysée la rdj à des muscles d'ypres en
prend à yviers on regarde là au niveau
de la signalétique la la main les
pointes et il lui dit prends prend heavy
moi je m'occupe du stefanovic qui qui
porte le ballon à ce moment là du match
calais blog était en défense sur le 55
normalement il défend en main pour le 55
mais là sur un repli est à son deuxième
copain qui lui dit non en prend prend
ivy moi je prends le porteur de balle
lui il écoute pas il n'est pas concentré
on voit que les deux joueurs défendent
le même ici on a agi qui va être tout
seul et ça nous fait notre donne qu il y
aurait 10 reprend le reprend le quai les
bleus vivent en trottinant ya dunk donc
voilà ça c'est le le côté négatif de
notre ami caleb l'offre encore une
dernière parce que je suis pas sympa
donc là il anticipe l'écran non là c'est
bon c'est une action positive par nous
alors c'est bon on passe sur le positif
c'est donc là il anticipe l'écran ils le
voient arriver ça doit annoncer par
armando bécotte ici vous voyez que les
pieds sont directement placé
et du coup on va se mettre en vitesse
réelle pour commencer et du coup il va
vraiment contester le pick and roll il
va casser la tacc donc ici j'anticipe
l'écran je glisse bien dans l'écran
parce qu'il a des longs segments et
qu'il est et qu'il est quand même mobile
et derrière il y en a oublié un petit
peu et voilà ça on veut attendre sa de
calais blob et cette partie ce côté là
du jour qu'on veut voir ici on va être
chaud de la défense mois du ballon
stefanovic encore lui journée par les
shooteurs exceptionnelle qui a plus de
40 % d'ici à trois points sur la saison
il ya un écran il en a déjà mis trois ou
quatre d'affilée dans ce match-là
contre pour de north carolina
caleb love lie à l'écran qui est posée
par pareille vie va très bien contester
le tir il ne va pas se laisser prendre
hop emma longueur de bras
pour contester je sais que stefanovich
les rapports en drive parce que c'est
pas un slasher donc je vais venir mettre
les bras pour contester en cloud that
les appuis sont bien placés pour
contester derrière le drive si jamais je
vais pas sauter dans une fente et
derrière on replace les pieds pour
contester main gauche et je vais mettre
une pression
directement sur le joueur parce que je
sais qu'il ne prendra pas part le
dribble
et donc c'est une défense
comme on l'attend de la part de caleb
love en vitesse réelle
un plat contestation je me replace voilà
au ralenti pour ceux qui aiment bien les
défenseurs intelligent
je sors de l'écran
et je me replace voilà donc il ya des
outils encore une fois on disait tout à
l'heure avec ivy les outils il a des
outils il sait pas forcément ce n'est
pas un aussi bon
joueur dont le déplacement latéral que
ivy par contre il ya quand même des la
puissance en bas du corps d une longueur
très intéressante pour en faire un
défenseur
correct ou moins correct en nba
l'action suivante on échange le même
système on va avoir un flou qui joue
demain vitesse réelle il est là il
vacille on sait très bien ils sont en
train de faire au moins fait 8 9 point
ce système là donc c'est très bien quoi
s'attendre il ya un petit retard dans le
décalage mais je suis long je suis
rapide je vais contester le tir et il
n'y aura pas de drops je voulais me
ralentit on passe rapidement parce qu'on
en a déjà vu en juste avant petit retard
mais je suis rapide
avec ma longueur de bras je conteste le
tir sans non plus sauter dans la fente
ici il est là
stefanovic toujours lui
je glisse bien
je vais pas laisser un tir à trois
points je suis concentré sur mon joueur
encore une fois un floppy et cette
fois-ci même y avoir un contre qui va
amener à une transition
fan de départ dribbles et ensuite un bon
kick extérieur pour brady manette shoot
à trois points et ça fait ficelle donc
si une grosse séquence la 25 secondes de
caleb love c'est tout ce que je peux
aimer chez calais bluff sans finir au
scoring voilà quand on vous dit que
c'est un joueur qui est très porté sur
le four ces points c'est vrai dans une
certaine mesure il ya aussi tout ce côté
là que je vais attendre chez lui et
buvait il qui va m'intéresser pour un
joueur nba nous je vous le mets en
vitesse réelle toute la séquence
d'abord par la défense on voit que c'est
un joueur qui peut vraiment existé loin
du ballon sur des fraudes et des
marquages
et derrière le bon qui quatre points
pour brady manech
voilà
doit encore avoir une séquence ici donc
il va être jour je pose un écran vous
voyez que c'est un joueur qui a des
petits peu par son épaisseur poser des
écrans il est peu concernée dans
l'action on voit qu'il fait pas trop
d'efforts dans cet écran qui mais il met
pas trop de volonté moi j'aime bien
aussi les joueurs qui
qui peuvent exister loin du ballon
lorsqu'il se voit pas et ça c'est bon
c'est mon plus grand qui vient vous dire
le jour
maintenant aujourd'hui des marquages
c'est un athlète
donc la passe il y aurait pu avoir donne
clé derrière on a la petite le petit
clic extérieur
le bon choix qui est pris ici des
marquages ligne de fond
et la bonne passe réflexes et ça fait
tirs à trois points ça fait ficelle
et je crois du coup et voilà on a bloqué
on revient avec ce petit dunk
donc voilà c'est caleb love sees ans
pour moi c'est impulse un second
d'arrière qu'un meneur de jeu lui je le
vois je le préfère dans un rôle de
deuxième créateur parce que c'est pas
encore assez propre maintenant comme on
peut le voir là je laisse tourner en
boucle il ya des vraies qualités
d'enfants dans son dribble il ya un vrai
premier pas il ya un tir extérieur
notamment une capacité à se créer son
propre tir à trois points à haut volume
à distance nba qu'on appréciera il y a
des longs bras on a dix ans de 110 cm
d'envergure
pour pouvoir être un bon défenseur donc
voilà on va avoir ce jour moi je les
points l'instant fans ma loterie je
pense qu'il peut il peut rester normal
au tri ça dépendra avec les joueurs dits
ligue et les joueurs qui vont jouer dans
les championnats
outre-atlantique donc là on va penser à
la nba les ou bien l'europe est ce qui
peut glisser ou pas pour l'instant je
les loteries
jeux le jeu l'est moins que avis
parce que je trouve moins athlétiques je
le trouve moins fluide je préfère la
spontanéité de ivy et je préfère le
aussi le tir
de la vie même s'il n'ya pas encore ce
ces décalages balandre dites moi ce que
vous en pensez de ce joueur il ya
beaucoup de gens qui l'aiment fort qui
l'an dernier on était très frustré et
qui cette année sont tombés amoureux
on voit que comme quoi le cas où le
contexte collectif est important l'an
dernier dans une équipe sans spécifier
les genres quatre pivots qui pouvait pas
prendre un tir à plus de de deux pas du
panier lui arrivait pas existé lors
d'une équipe avec pas mal de spacing
avec des pics qui peuvent écarter le jeu
tout de suite il est bien plus
intéressant
ça que les me contre comme tes fans des
knicks tu vois c'est peut-être plus
accessibles comme joueur parce que je
pense pas que les knicks seront daube 5
de draft en tout cas je l'espère pas on
le préfère en même temps mais pour un
joueur pour une équipe
qui galèrent peut-être fin de loterie
peut-être 15 16e place voilà avoir un
bon joueur de complément qui peut
d'abord faire du bon et ensuite à terme
devenir un titulaire jouera les postes 1
2 avec du potentiel ça peut être très
intéressant
donc voilà écoutez je voulais finir les
clips en boucle pendant que moi je
vérifie en même temps les notifications
twitter
s'il ya des questions c'est à des
remarques n'hésitez pas
et puis sinon on écoute et on va
s'arrêter là ensuite
[Musique]
il y avait à l'âne qui devait peut-être
passé pour nous parler donc de dénier à
bidias
[Musique]
génial dit un contexte où washington
pour l'instant en faites pas il a été
pris dans les courses de noël familial
donc il ya la meilleure excuse du monde
c'est une fête fête de famille donc on
comprend qu'il sera pas là ce soir avec
nous mais on regarde ça offrait pour la
prochaine fois du clip nba nous
reviendra ensemble sûrement la semaine
prochaine si j'ai l'occasion nord-ouest
ne sert d'avoir un groupe respecte
encore une fois j'ai pas encore qu'il
n'hésitait pas aussi sur twitter a
demandé qui vous voulez avoir entendant
je vous rappelle que chaque jour sur
envergure
vous avez un article ou un scooter et
portes
hier c'était été donnée vignes diagonale
vie dans ses portes aujourd'hui au
regard de la programmation je sais pas
encore ce qui va être prévu ce qui est
sorti et voilà c'est chaque jour un
article ou un scooter et porte on a
toujours nos podcasts
ou un qui va arriver sur du linge en
panne ils jouent le jeu vous l'annoncer
en premier ici
excusez moi voulons pas de ma
respiration et puis on va avoir
dans les semaines qui suivent la un
nouveau live cette fois ci sur youtube
on va pouvoir parler de nos board on va
pouvoir parler de
tonneaux de nos couture et cetera avec
toute l'équipe envergure donc voilà sur
notre site toujours un article sur les
pour trouver le meilleur ailier possible
soit avancé équipe à alexandre le papa
du podcast le l'article sur les pivots
en nba qu'est ce qui fait que les pivots
pétrole aurait une valeur qui descend et
les
comment justifier d'acheter un pivot top
cinq top-10 de draft ci peut pas faire
autre chose que perdure imron nous
sommes vraiment une belle analyse par
alan on parle ici avec julien des
joueurs dont parlement pacte web qui est
une des six mais d'ores des joueurs que
vous allez pouvoir retrouver
probablement en nba ou en europe sur des
second tour des fins de premier tour
dans les années qui suivent et puis à
droite le scouting report des danaïdes
vie siècle arabia du lan champagny
fellers glitch et d'autres et même des
joueurs qui sont pas encore prévu pour
la prochaine draft scouts henderson
d'ici donc voilà en tout cas merci à
tous d'avoir été avec moi sur ce live
c'était vraiment cool ça fait du bien de
pouvoir parler de pouvoir poser pour
partager journée les cheminots pépite
n'hésitez pas à partager
à écouter ce qu'ont verdure vous
proposant des reproches des 10000
abonnés là donc on est moins bien passé
ça pour noël ce sera hyper sympa et puis
nous on va bientôt se retrouver sur sur
les réseaux et et puis comme je voulais
dire aussi d'autres formats donc bah
écoute et s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions moi je vais vous laisser là et
puis je vous souhaite des belles fait
passer un bon réveillon profiter de
votre famille profitez de vos proches
prenez soin de vous
une bonne année si on va pas d'ici là
aussi et
puis on se dira tout bientôt
sur envergure à la prochaine ciao